Two dice are rolled and we need to find the
probability of getting an even greater than
three Let's think of all the possibilities where we can
get an even greater than three under two on the
first dice and two on the second dice
the sum equals  Which is greater than 3 and a
three 2 and a four and so on up to two and a
six then a three and a two and a three and a
three and you realize that the list is really very long so
this is not the right  Approach Here's
a Simpler Method We Can Write the
Probability of Getting a Sum Greater than 3 as
1 Minus the Probability of Getting a Sum
Not Greater than Three This is Interesting What
Exactly We Did Here's
Probability of One Covers All the
Possibilities and We're Just  Removing the
possibilities and the sum is not greater than 3 so what we'll be left with
is all the
possibilities with some greater than 3 which is exactly what we want now this can also be written as
1 minus the probability
of getting a sum less than  And equal to 3 not
greater than also means less than and equal to now
think of the possibilities whether some is less than or equal to
3 there are only three true
cases one and one one on d1 and one on d2 sum
is two which is less  Day 3 One and Two and Two and
One These Two Cases Are When the Sum Equals Three Now You Know Why We Did This
The
Possibilities in This Case Are Way Lesser than the
One in the Previous Case This
Probability Will Be / 36 This  Can be written as
1 - 3/3 6 Three possibilities where the sum is less
than and equal to 3 out of 36 total
possibilities This equals 33 / 36 Which after being
reduced to its simplest
form equals
11/1 Think about it if we would  Have Solved It This
Way We Would Have Had to Write 33
[Music]
Possibilities
B